Hey everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference, held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Kim Mills was a guest host. We hope you like this episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》的主持人凯特琳·卢娜。本期节目是在2019年10月于华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会（APA）“技术、思想与社会”会议期间录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事金·米尔斯担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。你好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客节目，
that looks at the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm coming to you from APA's annual Technology Mind and Society Conference in Washington, D.C. That's a cross-disciplinary meeting that is examining psychology's role in advancing everything from virtual reality to artificial intelligence to the Internet of Things. Cameras are playing a greater and greater role in law enforcement, whether we're talking about cameras placed on dashboards and police cruisers or cameras that officers wear as part of their uniforms. But how effective are cameras in police encounters? What do they tell us about police citizen interactions and do cameras ever lie? Our guest today is Dr. Nick Camp, a postdoctoral researcher at Stanford University, where he received his Ph.D. after completing his BA at Columbia University.
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯，现在是在华盛顿特区举行的APA年度“技术、思想与社会”会议现场。这是一场跨学科会议，旨在审视心理学在推动从虚拟现实、人工智能到物联网等各个领域发展中的作用。摄像头在执法中的作用越来越大，无论是安装在仪表盘和警车上的摄像头，还是警员制服上佩戴的摄像头。但摄像头在警察执法过程中到底有多有效？它们向我们揭示了哪些关于警察与公民互动的信息？摄像头会撒谎吗？我们今天的嘉宾是斯坦福大学的博士后研究员尼克·坎普博士，他在哥伦比亚大学获得学士学位后，在斯坦福大学获得了博士学位。
His primary research focus examines racial disparities in the everyday encounters between police officers and citizens. To understand the causes and consequences of these inequities, he draws on a range of of methods, from computational studies of officers' body-worn camera footage, to experiments in community and lab settings, to analyses of traffic stop data. Dr. Camp, thank you for joining us. Thank you for having me. So let me start by asking you, how common are cameras in police work today? Is every police force in America using them or considering using them?
他的主要研究重点是考察警察与公民日常接触中的种族差异。为了理解这些不平等现象的成因和后果，他运用了一系列研究方法，从对警员随身摄像头拍摄画面的计算研究，到社区和实验室环境中的实验，再到对交通拦截数据的分析。坎普博士，感谢您参加我们的节目。谢谢邀请。那么，我想先问您，摄像头在当今的警务工作中有多普遍？美国的每个警察部门都在使用或考虑使用它们吗？
So a recent survey shows that almost every police department in the country is either deploy these cameras or is planning to in the near future. And, you know, this is a rare reform that both police agencies and the public have been in favor of. So it's been a pretty rapid roll out of this technology. So how are cameras changing police work? And on balance, would you say that change is more for the good? So there's a few different ways and a few different effects that people have looked at with these cameras. So the first early studies have just looked at does having these cameras make a difference in police community trust? And the results are mixed, but on the whole, simply having police officers recording these encounters gives citizens a sense
最近的一项调查显示，全国几乎每个警察部门要么已经部署了这些摄像头，要么计划在不久的将来部署。你知道，这是一项罕见的改革，警察机构和公众都对此表示支持。因此，这项技术的推广速度非常快。那么，摄像头是如何改变警务工作的呢？总的来说，您认为这种改变是利大于弊吗？人们对这些摄像头进行了多方面的研究，也观察到了不同的效果。早期的研究主要关注佩戴这些摄像头是否能改善警民信任。结果好坏参半，但总的来说，仅仅让警员记录这些接触过程，就能给公民一种
of security that police officers will be held accountable for their actions. So other research has looked at what we can actually see on these videos, and there, the data is also kind of mixed. In many cases, the footage can be kind of ambiguous, so it's hard to tell. But my research looks at the language and what these cameras capture about everyday interactions. And I think this is really a new source of data for departments and can really be used to measure police reform for good. So how can the footage be ambiguous? I mean, you know, camera is a camera.
安全感，让他们觉得警员的行为会受到监督。其他研究则关注我们在这些视频中到底能看到什么，这方面的数据也比较混杂。在许多情况下，画面可能比较模糊，很难判断。但我的研究关注的是语言，以及这些摄像头捕捉到的日常互动。我认为这确实为各部门提供了一种新的数据来源，可以真正用于衡量警务改革的成效。那么，视频怎么会模糊呢？我的意思是，摄像头就是摄像头，
It takes a picture of what's happening, right? I mean, how could it be open to interpretation? That's right. Well, the hope was, you know, the camera doesn't lie. and simply putting a camera on every police officer would give us an unbiased view of what's actually happening in these encounters. But unfortunately, the camera is positioned on the police officer about chest level. So if you imagine filming a movie with a camera at that level, you don't see a whole lot. And the fact that it's filmed from the police officer's perspective, research by Broderick Turner and others has shown that this kind of leads people to empathize with the officer.
它拍下了正在发生的事情，对吧？我的意思是，它怎么可能还有解读空间呢？没错。嗯，人们的希望是，摄像头不会撒谎，给每位警员配备摄像头将为我们提供一个关于这些接触中实际发生情况的公正视角。但不幸的是，摄像头是安装在警员胸部位置的。所以，如果你想象一下用那个高度的摄像头拍电影，你其实看不到太多东西。而且，由于它是从警员的角度拍摄的，布罗德里克·特纳等人的研究表明，这会导致人们对警员产生共鸣。
So you're really getting literally one point of view in these interactions. Has there been thought given to changing where the camera is worn, like soldiers wear cameras on their helmets now? So there are a few, the technology is advancing quite rapidly. So some police departments are trying to position cameras in other locations in the uniform. But the fact of the matter is at the end of the day, it's going to be on the police officer. And so some of these are just limitations of the footage. So your research has used body camera footage to look at racial disparities and how police officers communicate with citizens. What have you found?
所以，你在这些互动中确实只得到了一个视角。有没有考虑过改变摄像头的佩戴位置，比如现在士兵把摄像头戴在头盔上？确实有一些，技术正在迅速进步。所以一些警察部门正在尝试将摄像头放置在制服的其他位置。但事实是，归根结底，它还是会戴在警员身上。因此，其中一些只是画面的局限性。那么，您的研究利用随身摄像头画面来观察种族差异以及警员如何与公民沟通。您发现了什么？
So this was a project that started. Originally, we were planning to look at the video from these interactions. And again, since the camera's at chess level, we didn't really see a whole lot of the community members that police officers were talking to. But I noticed as I was watching this footage that the words were coming in loud and clear. And so what we did was we looked at the words that officers were using in. their conversations with black and white drivers that they stop. And we found using a range of different methods that police officers communicate more respectfully when they're talking to white drivers than when they're talking to African Americans. Do you know, has your research indicated who's more
这是一个启动的项目。最初，我们计划观察这些互动中的视频。同样，由于摄像头在胸部位置，我们并没有真正看到太多警员正在交谈的社区成员。但我注意到，在观看这些画面时，谈话内容听得非常清楚。因此，我们所做的是分析警员在与他们拦截的黑人和白人司机交谈时所使用的词汇。我们通过一系列不同的方法发现，警员在与白人司机交谈时比与非裔美国人交谈时表现得更尊重。您知道，您的研究是否表明谁受
heavily influenced by the body cameras, whether it's the police or the civilians? That's a great question. One of our current projects is asking police officers and community members to look at the same interaction and see how their judgments about how respectful the officers being or how combative the drivers being, how that might differ across perspectives. So that's a really great point and it's something that we're looking into. So we don't know yet whether civilians are also more respectful. Do they always know that the cop is wearing a camera? So that differs from agency to agency. Some agencies make a point of having officers, you know, mentioned that they have a camera in the recording. Other agencies, the policy is just for the officer to turn
随身摄像头的影响更大，是警察还是平民？这是一个很好的问题。我们目前的一个项目是要求警员和社区成员观看同一段互动，看看他们对警员表现得多么尊重或司机表现得多么好斗的判断，在不同视角下会有什么不同。所以这是一个非常好的观点，也是我们正在研究的内容。所以我们还不知道平民是否也表现得更尊重。他们总是知道警察戴着摄像头吗？这因机构而异。一些机构会特意让警员提到他们正在录音。其他机构的政策只是要求警员在
on the camera before they make contact with the driver. So these are all great questions, and I think it's an empirical question is whether announcing the camera put citizens at ease more than simply having it on. What about individuals' right to privacy? Do you have any right to privacy if a police officer is stopping you? Can you say, I want you to turn that camera off? That's a great question. And I think as these cameras and the footage they capture are being deployed, I think we're going to have more of these kinds of questions as to who can access the footage and what circumstances. As of right now, it's lawful for police officers to make these recordings. And to my knowledge, I don't think you can ask that encounter not be recorded.
与司机接触前打开摄像头。所以这些都是很好的问题，我认为宣布摄像头是否比仅仅佩戴它更能让公民感到安心，这是一个实证问题。那么个人的隐私权呢？如果警员拦截你，你是否有任何隐私权？你能说，我希望你关掉那个摄像头吗？这是一个很好的问题。我认为随着这些摄像头及其捕捉到的画面被部署，我们将会有更多关于谁可以在什么情况下访问这些画面的问题。目前，警员进行这些记录是合法的。据我所知，你不能要求不记录那次接触。
But for example, there's ongoing debates about whether police officers should have access to that body camera footage. If so, can they view it before or after they give a state about an incident? Can the public view this? And really, this is a frontier, and this is a place where psychologists can help inform these policies. So there's no standard procedure at this point for how and where these videos are stored? You're saying that we just don't know yet. It's still being shaken out?
但例如，关于警员是否应该有权访问这些随身摄像头画面，目前仍存在争议。如果可以，他们是在陈述事件经过之前还是之后查看？公众可以查看吗？这确实是一个前沿领域，也是心理学家可以帮助为这些政策提供参考的地方。所以目前还没有关于这些视频如何以及在哪里存储的标准程序？您的意思是说我们还不知道？这还在摸索中？
That's right. There's differences in agencies as to how long videos are stored for, because as you imagine, it's very easy for police departments to accumulate tons and tons of videos, what purposes they're being used for. So this is really a rapidly developing field. So what do we learn from, say, dash cameras that are different from what we might learn from a body camera? So dash cameras are interesting because you can see both actors on them. There's some new technologies that pair dash cameras with might.
没错。各机构在视频存储时长方面存在差异，因为你可以想象，警察部门很容易积累海量的视频，以及它们被用于什么目的。所以这确实是一个快速发展的领域。那么，我们从仪表盘摄像头中学到的东西与从随身摄像头中学到的有什么不同？仪表盘摄像头很有趣，因为你可以看到画面中的两个当事人。有一些新技术将仪表盘摄像头与
microphones or with body cameras, you can get different views on the same event. One piece of research that's been really interesting, Yale Grinot, and colleagues have used eye tracking to look at how people, when they view dashboard camera videos, where they're actually looking in the scene. And again, people's pre-existing beliefs and trust in the police can guide where they're actually watching in these interactions. So again, it's another great opportunity and another rich source of data. But it's also something that we have to remember that individual minds are going to be viewing and interpreting.
麦克风或随身摄像头配对，你可以从同一事件中获得不同的视角。一项非常有趣的研究是，耶鲁大学的格里诺特及其同事使用眼动追踪技术来观察人们在观看仪表盘摄像头视频时，实际上在看场景中的什么位置。同样，人们预先存在的信念和对警察的信任会引导他们在这些互动中关注的地方。所以，这又是另一个很好的机会和丰富的数据来源。但我们也必须记住，个人的思想会去观看和解读这些内容。
So what's happening with body cameras and training in police forces right now? I mean, is that something that is discussed? And when you're in the police academy, you're learning how to use a body cam and when to turn that on, when to turn on a dash cam. What's the training like right now?
那么，目前警察部队中随身摄像头和培训的情况如何？我的意思是，这是一个讨论的话题吗？当你在警察学院时，你是否在学习如何使用随身摄像头以及何时打开它，何时打开仪表盘摄像头？现在的培训是什么样的？
So first of all, police officers love body cameras. They have the belief that having these interactions recorded in case they get a complaint will protect them. So it's in police officers' interests to properly use these cameras and record their interactions. One thing that is kind of on the cutting edge is using these recordings for training purposes. And this is something that my team and I are very interested in, not just for looking at specific acute instances. such as use of force cases, but looking at police officers communication. So one of the greatest tools that a police officer has is their words. And if we can better train police officers and how to communicate with the public,
首先，警员们非常喜欢随身摄像头。他们认为，如果这些互动被记录下来，万一他们收到投诉，这将保护他们。因此，正确使用这些摄像头并记录他们的互动符合警员的利益。目前处于前沿的一件事是将这些记录用于培训目的。这也是我和我的团队非常感兴趣的事情，不仅仅是为了观察特定的紧急情况，例如使用武力的案例，而是观察警员的沟通方式。所以警员拥有的最伟大的工具之一就是他们的语言。如果我们能更好地培训警员如何与公众沟通，
it can prevent many of these interactions from escalating to the use of force. And it is pretty much acceptable among police officers. You said that they really like them, and you said that the public likes these cameras as well, but I know there's been a lot of controversy in certain cases. I mean, a lot of cases that make it into the media, and it turns out that there's some dispute over what really happened, and you talked about the difference in angles. So is it really all that popular, basically?
它可以防止许多此类互动升级为使用武力。而且这在警员中几乎是可以接受的。您说他们真的很喜欢，而且您说公众也喜欢这些摄像头，但我知道在某些情况下存在很多争议。我的意思是，很多进入媒体的案例，结果发现对到底发生了什么存在一些争议，您谈到了角度的差异。所以，它基本上真的那么受欢迎吗？
So the challenge is that many times when we're talking about body camera footage, it's in the context of particular incidents, trying to decide who is in the right, who is in the wrong, and specifically in very ambiguous incidents. And unfortunately, that ambiguous, those, ambiguous circumstances are the cases where people's individual biases might shape how they interpret that footage. It's already can be a pretty fuzzy signal. So I think that's one reason why we see a lot of debate over the meaning of particular videos and what they capture and what they don't
挑战在于，很多时候当我们谈论随身摄像头画面时，是在特定事件的背景下，试图决定谁对谁错，特别是在非常模糊的事件中。不幸的是，那些模糊的情况正是人们的个人偏见可能影响他们如何解读这些画面的案例。它本身可能就是一个相当模糊的信号。所以我认为这就是为什么我们看到对特定视频的含义以及它们捕捉到什么和没捕捉到什么存在很多争论的原因之一。
capture. But at the same time, one of the things I hope to show my research is there are thousands of interactions between police officers and the public, and many of them are not ambiguous, and particularly the words that officers use. Many are evidently respectful or disrespectful. So what I'm hoping is that in addition to using these videos as evidence in particular cases, we can use it as a source of data to look at policing as a whole. Are you doing, or is anybody doing research into the change in language that may be occurring as a result of using cameras? So, yeah, that's a very tricky question because, you know, it always comes down to like, what's the baseline?
但与此同时，我希望通过我的研究展示的一件事是，警员与公众之间有成千上万次互动，其中许多并不模糊，特别是警员使用的词汇。许多明显是尊重或不尊重的。所以我希望，除了将这些视频作为特定案件的证据外，我们还可以将其作为数据来源来审视整个警务工作。您是否正在，或者有人正在研究由于使用摄像头而可能发生的语言变化？所以，是的，这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为你知道，它总是归结为，基准是什么？
Yeah, what can you compare it to, right? Not to mention that these cameras are proliferating so rapidly, it's hard to get a control group. So that is a challenging question, and I don't know if we're past the point where we're going to be able to answer what's the effect of having body cameras versus what can we learn from the footage that they're capturing. So what else are you looking at now? Where's your research headed? So there's a few different directions. One very basic psychological question is in addition to, you know, what's the information captured in these recordings? What can these recordings tell us about how people form or lose their trust in the police?
是的，你可以拿什么来比较，对吧？更不用说这些摄像头扩散得如此之快，很难找到对照组。所以这是一个具有挑战性的问题，我不知道我们是否已经过了能够回答拥有随身摄像头的影响与我们能从它们捕捉到的画面中学到什么之间的区别的阶段。那么您现在还在研究什么？您的研究方向是什么？有几个不同的方向。一个非常基本的心理学问题是，除了这些记录中捕捉到的信息外，这些记录能告诉我们人们是如何形成或失去对警察的信任的？
So in some research, we've been looking at police officers tone of voice. So we filter out the words from these recordings. And so you're left with something like a Charlie Brown, grown-up type of language, like bomp-a-bom-bomp. And we're interested in how, one, this tone might differ when police officers are talking to white and black men. Two, have people's preexisting trust in the police shapes what they hear in that Charlie Brown signal. And then third, if you only expose people to police officers' interactions with white drivers or black drivers, how would that shape their perception of the police department? And what we're finding is first, police officers use a more respectful tone when they're talking to white men. Second, that people's own individual trust in the police shapes how trustworthy they perceive that tone.
在一些研究中，我们一直在观察警员的语调。我们过滤掉了这些记录中的词汇。所以你剩下的是类似《花生漫画》中成年人那种语言，比如“蹦-啊-蹦-蹦”。我们感兴趣的是，第一，当警员与白人和黑人男性交谈时，这种语调可能有何不同。第二，人们预先存在的对警察的信任如何塑造他们在那个“蹦-蹦”信号中听到的内容。然后第三，如果你只让人们接触警员与白人司机或黑人司机的互动，这将如何塑造他们对警察部门的看法？我们发现的是，首先，警员在与白人男性交谈时使用更尊重的语调。其次，人们自己对警察的个人信任塑造了他们认为这种语调有多值得信赖。
And then third, that people who are exposed to police officer interactions with black men think that the police department is less trustworthy than those who listen to many interactions with white men. So that's kind of one additional way we can use this to expose different people to the same exact interaction. In other research, we're looking at what's the relationship, between these acute instances of police violence and how those might color the everyday interactions between police officers and communities of color. So for me, what's really exciting is that having access
然后第三，接触过警员与黑人男性互动的人认为警察部门不如那些听过许多与白人男性互动的人那么值得信赖。所以这是我们可以利用这一点让不同的人接触到完全相同的互动的另一种方式。在其他研究中，我们正在观察这些警察暴力的紧急事件与这些事件如何影响警员与有色人种社区之间的日常互动之间的关系。所以对我来说，真正令人兴奋的是，拥有访问
to body camera footage really opens up a whole new world of questions. And I think it'll really help us understand how this relationship can be built and how trust can be formed or eroded in these interactions. Are you looking at differences with other demographic groups, for example, women or Latinos or people of ambiguous racial or ethnic backgrounds? So absolutely. In our initial study, we looked at just black and white drivers,
随身摄像头画面的权限确实开启了一个全新的问题世界。我认为这将真正帮助我们理解这种关系是如何建立的，以及在这些互动中信任是如何形成或被侵蚀的。您是否在观察与其他人口统计学群体的差异，例如女性或拉丁裔，或具有模糊种族或族裔背景的人？当然。在我们最初的研究中，我们只观察了黑人和白人司机，
single month. We did look at gender. Police officers generally use more respectful language with female drivers. But in our next way of research, we're really opening it up to look at a wider range of interactions. One of the challenges from our approach, since we focus so much on language, is when police officers are conversing with people who English is not their native language, that's a challenge we have to deal with, especially since many police officers in the department we study can speak Spanish. But I think these are challenges that will advance our understanding. So initially we focused on one specific contrast, but hopefully we can learn more about policing across a range of identities. What got you interested in this aspect of psychology?
一个月的时间。我们确实观察了性别。警员通常对女性司机使用更尊重的语言。但在我们的下一波研究中，我们确实在扩大范围，观察更广泛的互动。由于我们非常关注语言，我们方法的一个挑战是，当警员与英语不是母语的人交谈时，这是我们必须处理的挑战，特别是因为我们研究的部门中的许多警员会说西班牙语。但我认为这些挑战将推进我们的理解。所以最初我们专注于一个特定的对比，但希望我们能更多地了解跨越一系列身份的警务工作。是什么让您对心理学的这个方面感兴趣？
So my path has been kind of a backwards one. I didn't really think that much about race until I became a psychologist. And for me, one of the powerful messages of psychology is it can show you different ways of seeing and thinking about the world. And for someone who, before he took a psychology course, believe that people could just put their identities at the door and, you know, be a good student or be a good worker. It really took the research on stereotype threat and a lot of social psychology to just show to me that that wasn't the case. And I think once I was disabused of that idea, I really became hungry for to learn more. So as in terms of when I became interested in policing specifically, a lot of my early work in grad school was looking at face perception.
所以我的道路有点倒退。在我成为心理学家之前，我并没有真正考虑过种族问题。对我来说，心理学的一个有力信息是它可以向你展示看待和思考世界的不同方式。对于一个在参加心理学课程之前，相信人们可以把他们的身份放在门外，成为一名好学生或好员工的人来说，刻板印象威胁的研究和社会心理学的大量研究确实向我表明情况并非如此。我认为一旦我摆脱了那个想法，我就真的渴望学习更多。至于我何时对警务工作产生兴趣，我在研究生院的许多早期工作都是观察面部感知。
And so I was spending hours and hours a day, morphing faces, running these lab studies with faces. And Michael Brown was shot, and I thought, okay, like, why am I doing this research? I think perception is incredibly important, and I think that can tell us a lot. But at the end of the day, what I really found interesting about that work was that it could speak to broader issues of racial inequality. And so I think that really pushed me to focus on not just these very basic research projects, but looking at how race and racial inequality plays out in the real world. Well, thank you. This is very interesting. I'd like to keep tabs on what you're doing because I think it's important work and it's going to help reduce the inequities that we
所以我每天花几个小时，变形面孔，进行这些面部实验室研究。迈克尔·布朗被枪杀，我想，好吧，我为什么要进行这项研究？我认为感知非常重要，我认为这可以告诉我们很多。但归根结底，我发现这项工作真正有趣的地方在于它可以触及种族不平等的更广泛问题。所以我认为这确实推动我不仅关注这些非常基础的研究项目，而且关注种族和种族不平等如何在现实世界中发挥作用。好吧，谢谢。这非常有趣。我想跟进您的工作，因为我认为这是一项重要的工作，它将有助于减少我们在
experience in our country. Really appreciate you're joining us today, Dr. Camp. Thank you for having me. So before we go, let me remind listeners that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. And please consider rating us in iTunes. We'd appreciate that as well. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other informative podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about new psychological
国家所经历的不平等。非常感谢您今天参加我们的节目，坎普博士。谢谢邀请。在我们离开之前，提醒听众我们想听到你们的声音。你可以将你的评论和想法通过电子邮件发送到 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们也会非常感激。 《心理学谈话》是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他信息丰富的播客，例如关于新心理学的 APA 期刊对话
research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on. Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, wherever you get your podcasts. And you can also go to our website, www.combeatingofpsychology.org, and listen to more episodes. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
研究和关于心理学实践的进度记录。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。